TROOPS WILL FLOOD INTO EASTERN
UKRAINE, THEN ALL BETS ARE OFF.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> OBVIOUSLY PUTIN HAS HISS
MISSION AND HE CLEARLY DOES SEE
HIMSELF IN THE WAY THAT
PROFESSOR COHEN JUST OUTLINED.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S BEEN A MAJOR
SORT OF ARGUMENT OVER UKRAINE,
BUT PUTIN AND THE RUSSIANS HAVE
BY TREATY THEIR BIG BLACK SEA
FLEET IN SEVASTOPOL IN THE
CRIMEA.
THERE'S NO INDICATION THAT THE
NEW UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT WAS
GOING TO CHANGE THAT REALITY AT
ALL.
YOU SAY THAT PUTIN HAS
TELEGRAPHED WHAT HIS AIMS ARE
AND THAT HE'S NOT A THUG, WELL,
LOOK, I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
EXPLAIN TO ME HOW HE AND US CAN
JUSTIFY THE TRUMPING UP OF THIS
HYSTERIA IN THE CRIMEA WHICH HAS
GIVEN THE RUSSIANS THE ABILITY
TO DO WHAT THEY'RE DOING,
WHETHER IT WAS THE TRUMPED-UP
CHANGE OF GOVERNMENT IN THE
CRIMEAN PARLIAMENT, WHETHER THE
TRUMP-UP CALL BY THIS GOVERNMENT
FOR RUSSIANS TO COME IN AND
PROTECT THEM WHEN THEY WERE NOT
BEING KILLED, PROFESSOR COHEN,
NO VIOLENCE IN THE CRIMEA.
WHETHER IT'S BEEN THE
HORRENDOUS -- AND I'VE DONE A
LOT OF REPORTING ON INSIGHTMENT
TOWARD WAR IN RUSSIA.
NO, NO, THIS IS THE FACTS.
NOW YOU HAVE THE DOER DEBATING
AN ANNEXATION LAW.
ALL OF THIS IS TRUMPED UP TO
PROVIDE PUTIN WITH WHAT YOU SAY
AND THAT HIS DESIRE TO PROTECT
THEIR INTERESTS AND TO KEEP HIS
SPHERE OF INFLUENCE.
>> PROFESSOR COHEN.
>> THE EXTREMISM DIDN'T COME
FROM RUSSIA.
IT WAS COMING FROM WESTERN
UKRAINE.
WE'VE LEFT A LARGE PART OF THE
STORY OUT.
THERE'S A SMALL BUT RESOLUTE AND
DETERMINED RIGHT-WING
NATIONALIST MOVEMENT IN UKRAINE.
IT'S QUASIFASCIST AND IT IS
DICTATING TERMS TO THIS
PARLIAMENT IN KIEV WHICH IS NOT
LEGITIMATE IN LAW OR
CONSTITUTIONAL.
THIS PARLIAMENT WHICH IS A RUNT
PARLIAMENT BECAUSE THEY BANNED
THE TWO THAT REPRESENTED THE
EAST HAVE BEEN PASSING
ANTI-RUSSIAN LEGISLATION.
THEY BANNED THE USE OF RUSSIAN
AS AN OFFICIAL LANGUAGE.
IT ISN'T RUSSIA THAT'S BEEN
SPEWING THIS IDEOLOGICAL
DESTABILIZING MESSAGE, IT'S BEEN
COMING FROM THE WEST.
AND HERE THE WORST PART IS THAT
HAS BEEN -- THAT HATRED HAS BEEN
SUPPORTED BY WASHINGTON AND
BERIS ELS IN EMBRACING THIS WEST
UKRAINIAN MOVEMENT.
THAT MUST STOP.
>> WE'RE UP AGAINST THE CLOCK,
UNFORTUNATELY, BUT TO BE
CONCLUDED.
PROFESSOR COHEN AND CHRISTIANE
AMANPOUR.
YOU HEARD VITALY CHURKIN SAYING
EARLIER TODAY THAT AT FAULT FOR
ALL OF THIS ARE WHAT HE CALLED
FASCISTS AND ANTI-SEMITES IN
UKRAINE UNIRIGHT NOW.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE REALLY CAREFUL
BY PUTTING THAT ACROSS AS A
FAST.
>> THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> HE MAY HAVE DONE.
ARE YOU TELLING ME, ARE YOU
SAYING THAT THE ENTIRE PRO
EUROPEAN --
>> OF COURSE NOT, I WAS ONLY
SAYING.
>> THAT IS WHAT THE RUSSIANS ARE
>> I WAS ONLY SAYING WHAT
VITALY --
>> THAT'S WHAT PROFESSOR COHEN
IS SAYING.
>> WE HEARD PROFESSOR COHEN SAY
IT AND I WAS POINTING OUT THAT A
RUSSIAN OFFICIAL AT THE UNITED
NATIONS TODAY SAID WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL THIS,
FASCISTS AND ANTI-SEMITES IN
UKRAINE.
AM I SAYING THAT?
NO, I'M NOT.
BUT I AM SAYING THAT'S WHAT
VITALY CHURKIN SAID --
>> RIGHT.
AND WE HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL.
>> WE PLAYED IT FOR YOU.
>> I HEARD IT.
I HEARD IT.
WE JUST AS A NETWORK HAVE TO BE
REALLY CAREFUL NOT TO LUMP THE
ENTIRE PRO-EUROPEAN UKRAINIANS
INTO WHAT IS --
>> WE'RE NOT, I'M NOT.
>> -- WHICH ARE NATIONALISTIC
AND EXTREM